you know obviously didn't anticipate
being here
um in this position um disappointed
uh by it um understand that
you know um we better make some changes
in terms of
the things that we do we better look at
every aspect of it
um schematics personnel um
approach to business uh i'm committed to
that you know i'm not gonna
maintain status quo and and hope that
the outcome changes that's
you know that's the definition of
insanity do you
think that it's realistic that ben will
be back given the
the uh cap implications you know
you know i don't i don't i don't have a
clear assessment of of the overall
impact of the cap ramifications so i
might not have a
direct answer to your question but i
think it's reasonable to
to assume that there's a chance that
he's going to be back certainly um the
the depths of the ramifications of the
cap discussions
i am not privy to as i sit here right
now
well mike tomlin will make you privy to
it if ben roethlisberger comes back
without a new contract his cap number is
41.25 million dollar
there is the ramification especially if
the cap is as low as 175 although i
think they're going to find a way
through negotiations with the union to
keep it higher because it hurts the
teams that would otherwise have to have
a purge
of veteran players i don't think anyone
wants that for 2021
but you still got to deal with that
41.25 million shireen
which means if he comes back this almost
is like the drew brees situation late in
his career
every year they would fashion an
extension that kicks that can
farther down the road reduces the cap
now you take the salary
you shrink it to the minimum you convert
it to a guarantee
and it drops the cap number this year
but the cap number is still
there's only so much you can do to drop
this cap number
and you're eventually going to take a
huge cap hit when ben rothsberger
retires if he retires this year it's a
22 million dollar
cap hit and look if i'm roethlisberger
assuming they would want the 12 and a
half million dollars back that he hasn't
earned yet
that he received in signing bonus money
and remember signing bonus isn't free
money
it's advanced pay for future services
he could just dig in and wait and say
i'm
not extending my contract and you decide
what you want to do there's a 15 million
roster bonus that comes due on the third
day of the league year maybe they'll cut
him that's what calvin johnson should
have done
five years ago he retired and they they
came after him for money at a time when
his cap number was so bloated they were
probably going to cut him anyway
i think ben needs to learn from that and
force them to make their decision
and uh and then if he wants to retire
after the the new league year starts and
they have to carry the 41 million
cap charge so be it you know it's a
tough call it's a tough situation it's a
tough spot shireen
and and it's it's a lot more complicated
than tomlin made it out to be today he
just kind of punted on the question
by acting like he doesn't know what's
going on he sure knows what's going on
he absolutely does mike and you wrote
earlier today about the seahawks being
at a crossroads
this to me is a team that is at the
crossroads right now they have seven
players counting ben roethlisberger who
are scheduled to take up
71 of the cap space if it's at 182
million which is kind of the projection
at this point we don't know
exactly what it's going to be they have
19
unrestricted free agents 10 of those
started at least one game we know juju
is one of those free agents
this to me looks like a team that that
is either ready to rebuild or i know
they're in contention
every single year with mike tomlin but
you have a quarterback question
you have tons of free agents this is a
team mike i don't know if you agree or
not
that very much is at a crossroads right
now yeah they've got to make some big
decisions about who they're going to pay
who they're going to keep who they're
going to let go can they
can they keep juju smith schuster after
the browns is the browns
can they really do that will the fan
base forgive him
for his role in stirring up the browns
and giving the steelers one of the most
embarrassing playoff losses
ever and it was they hadn't lost the
browns at home in 17 years
they hadn't lost to the browns at home
since ben roethlisberger was drafted
that's how long it had been and in that
moment in that game to have it happen
the way it did
that leaves a mark and you just have to
wonder what changes will be made they
haven't won
uh many playoff games since going to the
super bowl
to cap the 2010 season they have two
playoff wins since 2011.
and you know at some point if this
continues
people are going to call more loudly
than ever
for a coaching change and you know we've
talked about this earlier in the week
the steelers don't do it because they
they don't that's their thing they keep
coaches forever
so they will resist firing mike tomlin
even if they get to a point two three
four years from now where
that's the kind of rebuilding they need
to do but i
i agree with you major changes coming
for the steelers
it's more of a reload than a rebuild
it's changing a tire
on a car that that temporarily slows
down but never really stops moving
and and we'll see what they can do but
if if they don't have roethlisberger
mason rudolph i know he played well in
the game against the browns that
that you know they they they played a
bunch of backups because they
they didn't really need it at all it
didn't matter to the steelers
i just don't know that's enough to make
rudolph your guy because we saw it
shireen in 2019. rudolph wasn't the
answer
doc hodges wasn't the answer i don't
think josh dobbs is the answer
and i don't know what they would do at
that point to find a quarterback if
ben's gone
i was surprised mike they didn't go out
and get a backup quarterback or draft
somebody they could groom after seeing
mason rudolph
and duck hodges when ben was out last
year in 2019
because they played 14 games 14 and a
half games
actually uh and they didn't see it they
knew neither one of those guys was their
franchise quarterback and now with ben
roethlisberger turning 39
in may in this huge cap hit we don't
know what his future is and they don't
know what the future is at the
quarterback position because they have
no backup
i think that ben falls into the category
of franchise quarterbacks who
don't want to have anyone else on the
depth chart who's
who's good frankly who's who's good
enough that makes him
think are they thinking about getting
rid of me and
and maybe they've made the strategic
decision we get the best from ben
roethlisberger if we don't have
his successor hovering over his shoulder
and we've seen plenty of quarterbacks
where that's been the case the problem
is
you're you're asking for a lost season
or at a minimum you're gonna have to
scramble to take whoever you can find
ryan fitzpatrick phillip rivers whoever
you can find
as a band-aid to get you to the next
year it's not a good situation for the
steelers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports